Lauren bobert appeared on Stephanie
rules program on MSNBC last night and it
was really humiliating absolutely
unhinged and humiliating for Lauren
bobert Lauren bobert of course has been
leading this auntie Kevin McCarthy
leading she's been involved in this
anti-kevin McCarthy
movement to the extent that it's a
movement in the Republican party they
have
um suggested everything from she might
nominate Donald Trump to who the hell
knows what else she appeared last night
with Stephanie Rule and you can tell
that she doesn't have any idea what's
going on she's stumbling around in the
dark she knows she's supposed to oppose
Kevin McCarthy uh and and her little
constituency is opposing Kevin McCarthy
but there's really no there there in
terms of the substance and Stephanie
rule makes this very very much apparent
you know what these names are but I'm
sure that you're going to see a lot of
names beginning to emerge because we're
showing that we are willing to work to
unify the Republican party and get the
by the way imagine that the idea I'm
fine with them doing this it's
self-destructive but the idea that
bobert's actions are unifying is
laughable right okay sure and maybe it's
going to be me and Kim Kardashian and
anyone else who can be out there would
you like me to nominate you tomorrow
how long are you willing to wait I mean
the American people voted you in you
said we could be here until the cherry
blossom you've got the power and every
day that passes that you're not doing
your jobs voters are saying hold on a
second I voted you in to get something
done right I don't know what these and
they're getting absolutely nothing done
as I've pointed out to you before and
the National Security risks that come
with it and the self-destructive risks
that come with it as well here's another
portion of this interview and again
bobert just doesn't know what she's
talking about she of course barely won
her race she has no business being in
elected office and you can tell she's
clueless actually I look at it in a very
different way I see it as congress not
spending money that they don't have
because every day that I've been in
Congress we've done exactly that so the
taxpayers are actually winning here uh
because Congress hasn't organized look
my conservative colleagues yeah I want
to by the way
this is uh you know when Marjorie Taylor
green was kicked off of her committees
one of the things I told you is we see
this as an embarrassment you've been
stripped of your duties you're being
sort of like sent home whatever
if you believe that Congress really
shouldn't do stuff if you are actually
one of these supposed small government
conservatives where you you kind of want
Congress to do and government to do as
little as possible you actually see some
of these things as wins and what bobert
is arguing I don't know if Republicans
are really think voters are thinking
about it this way but she's saying
listen uh we we run at a deficit and so
the longer Congress does nothing the
better it actually is financially now of
course the absurdity is taxpayer dollars
are still paying for what's going on in
the house chamber it's just they're
voting for speaker over and over again
it's still the same waste of money she
claims doing stuff is but she's trying
to tie in that small government ideology
in a way that's just laughable
on what the American people want to see
sure and with every passing day it's not
that Congress isn't spending money
anything that was put in place okay so
Stephanie rule making the argument I'm
making during Nancy Pelosi's term none
of that is going to stop and until you
put a speaker in place nothing that you
want to do is getting done right
well unfortunately the Senate took away
our Authority um to even work with a
budget of the next nine months Nancy
Pelosi is ruling with a dead hand anyway
they just
Stephanie rule is completely correct I
mean just a hundred percent completely
correct and then another funny moment
here where Stephanie rule points out to
Lauren bobert you barely won that secure
our Southern boy and then balance budget
and America the American voter does want
Congress to work together right look at
your last election you represent a red
District that Donald Trump handily won
and you won narrowly and the takeaway
for the entire midterms is that the
country said we are done with Hyper
partisanship we want Congress to get to
work and to work together we saw today
Mitch McConnell President Biden Mike
dewine them working together talking
infrastructure in Kentucky and what
you're doing today is blocking your own
party is that what your voters asked you
to do
so what I hear back at home all the time
for my constituents is they're Furious
about what the Democrats have been doing
all of this time they're Furious about
the Border crisis the energy crisis the
historic inflation and so much more and
we will handle these issues and conduct
serious oversight real soon when we get
the speaker's position right it's been
two days it's it's not the end of the
world we are going to come together we
tried to do this privately unfortunately
Kevin McCarthy wanted to take this
battle to the floor and that's where
we're at right now yeah so Stephanie
rule accurately and precisely exposing
that they don't even really know what
the end game is and as Lauren bobert
says it hasn't been that long we're
eventually going to come together at
this point enough damage has been done
that I mean listen eventually there's
going to be a speaker of the house if it
is indeed a republican speaker of the
house which most likely will be although
there's a scenario in which Hakeem
Jeffries becomes the speaker and just
nothing gets done because Republicans
would still be in the majority it will
be a weakened speaker it will be a
speaker lacking credibility and it will
be a Republican party lacking
credibility as well Hannity's been right
by saying they're turning this into a
clown show and they're turning this into
a game show and bobert becoming almost
like the spokesperson for this movement
she's already a clown show going in
making it even more so and uh I have to
tell you
it's horrible for the country I can't
control the fact that Republicans are
doing this and I would rather that they
didn't but to the extent that the AR
that they are doing it and are damaging
themselves I welcome it we'll have all
of the clips I played here on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and of course all of
these clips will be on our YouTube
channel make sure that you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show let's
make it to two million YouTube
subscribers this calendar year would be
a major accomplishment don't allow the
bystander effect to make you assume
someone else will subscribe be the
person who does it
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 when you go to hold on
bags.com Pacman and use the code Pacman
the link is down below